today's episode of answer the Internet
is brought to you by Roman the online
men's health company with all the
answers gone are the days of thinking
about baseball lineups to try to last
longer in bed
Roman swipes are here to help you with
that they are incredibly easy to use you
just rip them open wipe it on let it dry
good to go
gonna get Roman dot-com slash internet
right now you can get your Roman swipes
for just five bucks when you choose a
monthly plan go to get Roman comm slash
Internet to swipe today I'm Jim Gaffigan
you can see me in troop zero which is on
Amazon Prime On January 17th and I'm
touring I'm coming to your house to
murder you and I'm gonna ask the
Internet I'm gonna answer the Internet's
questions if you could only have knees
or elbows what would you pick I think
mmm
I think knees right oh that's true oh I
guess elbows right then you couldn't but
then you would then you imagine how fat
I would be would you rather spend the
rest of your life blind or inside an
Olive Garden you know that's I mean no
one wants I mean if you're blind and
you're listening it was it's I'm sure
it's great but uh but and Olive Garden's
not that bad is it
I mean it's not like you know I think
they have like breadsticks right and
Italian food is generally you can't ruin
it right would you rather be in shape
but feel fat or be fat and feel healthy
I think I'd rather be in shape and feel
fat right that's you can get over
feelings that's with alcohols for right
would you rather be the best-looking
dude in the world or just be able to
read minds
this is really weird because I can do
both of these already
I would I would rather be able to read
minds I mean that's a skill and you know
looks don't matter I mean they do
obviously would you rather have teeth
where your hair is or hair where your
teeth are first of all I don't have that
much hair and I just had a root canal so
I would rather I mean obviously I think
we got to go teeth right
Deaver hairs yeah yeah and then you'd
have to brush your scalp that's weird
right would you rather have a flock of
geese swarm to you every time you fart
never use a phone or computer again I
get used to the geese right I mean
there's part of me that like I don't
know if I can even go to the bathroom
without my phone at this point like is
it possible as I looked at some woman
she's like don't look at me would you
rather have no music for the rest of
your life or have all music be sung by
your significant other I mean how do I
answer that my tooth hurts I love my
wife if it was acceptable for men to
carry purses would you carry what would
you carry in your purse well first of
all I kind of have a murse that I keep
my comedy notes in and my lipstick yeah
I don't know it's weird I feel like
we're kind of doing the purse thing
anyway yeah particularly during the
summer cuz that's a guy you're like
where do I put this crap yeah
you look at me and you're like sunblock
sunblock an umbrella a tarp like where
would you put all your food - Jim you
fat slob would you rather be stuck in
Jurassic Park or Jumanji you know I
would say I think Jumanji right I mean I
know that like I don't remember that
much of Jumanji which Jumanji the jungle
40 years oh really
but dinosaurs you're eventually gonna
get eat right I would say avatar can I
say avatar would you rather get your
girlfriend pregnant when you're 16 or
get your wife pregnant when you're 60
first of all I hope my wife and my
girlfriend there were meaningful no
that's an old joke but I would say just
energy wise I you know I think I don't
you know I I'm open to all forms of life
no I would say if I had to choose I
would think sixties pretty old I know I
look like I'm 20 but when you're 16 you
have energy but you know people used to
do it when there were sixteen all the
time and I think Abraham in the Bible
was like a hundred and ten so I would
say either of them but I would if I had
to choose I'd pick I mean your
girlfriend sixteen hopefully she's 16 if
you're 16 how old is your girlfriend
what if your girlfriend was 60 and you
were 16 that's hot
[Laughter]
thank you alright thanks for watching
answer the internet with Jim Gaffigan
for more answer the internet videos
subscribe to our channel here you watch
Jim answer I don't know about 10
questions answer the internet the card
game 500 cards with the best most
interesting questions the Internet has
to offer I'm talking in philosophical
questions there's a sex question sports
questions you got marry [ __ ] kills you
have would you drivers all in one box
for you to play buy it right here and
for more Jim Gaffigan content check out
our clip from our podcast KFC radio down
here